in a world of legendary heroes one man
will rise to take all of the credit this
game has something that no one else will
[Music]
everybody has that game that they fell
in love with because they make an impact
those games were somebody's legacy well
this is my legacy a legacy I don't like
to see whatever it's not my legacy
I have a BA in Women's Studies what
exactly is Women's Studies Paul's
experiences of women and the
contributions they've made to inquiry
withdrawn quick thing I'm worried about
the time
David I'll move it as fast as I can it's
not my fault that these watermelons
don't explode like real heads I can get
you real heads not human that's
commitment I built your vision it's like
you're this brilliant painter and I'm
your favorite brush I'm just I'm tool to
create your masterpiece
I like that metaphor but it's not quite
right is it - seriously about your
noodle on my metaphor right now
I know that I can be difficult you can't
give up like the Beatles
together we make masterpieces I could
write the lyrics and the music and
everything but it would sound completely
different without the drums
wait I'm Ringo well yeah of course
you're Ringo I mean look somebody's got
to keep the beat oh my god at least you
brought me breakfast oh this is mine
it's prescription a prescription bagel
legally you're actually not allowed to
ask me about
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our program begins now oh my god I'm
excited for this I was gonna try and get
you hyped but you're doing it yourself
we can do this though hi I'm Jesse Cox I
am a massive Larry and fan I am up here
gonna host this fun panel that we have
in store for you today I'm really
excited this is the gameplay reveal
panel for baldur's gate 3
[Applause]
we've got about 10 minutes of game
playing and about eight spreadsheets a
few pie charts and 45 minutes of QA
right pretty much and we know what you
love lots of spreadsheets numbers lots
of those anyway all right how many of
you by show of hands are big Larian fans
all right and how many of you were like
Baldur's Gate I love that and by show of
ice room two hands how many of you are
fans of both I got everyone to do the
wave I'm feeling really good about that
all right we are going to look I could
talk all day I I could but no one cares
what I think because all of you are here
to see this man Sven Fink is going to
play for you Baldur's Gate three and I'm
gonna shut up and let him do that
because this is going to be the coolest
thing you will ever see and I'm gonna
just hand it over to you
[Applause]
hold on wait a minute wait a minute I
fall so we can get louder than that this
is gonna be crazy
we had to turn people away there people
still outside you'd be even louder to
make them sadder
louder get excited Baldur's Gate three
scream for this man
[Applause]
thank you I love you too
so what you're about to see is a game
that's still in development so it's
literally pre-alpha footage we're not
gonna show you a video we're gonna just
play I don't know what's gonna happen
furthermore to make it even more
exciting the save gape system is broken
so that means that if I die if it's a
party wipe I'll just have to restart so
we'll try not to have that happen if you
see a Birkin available you will see
something it's something that we see -
we'll fix it
we still have a whole bunch of time
before it's gonna be ready I it was
announced that it's going to early
access we actually wanted to announce it
today but people were very excited about
sign on saying it for us so and it's
gonna be an early access in a couple of
months we don't know exactly when when
it's ready for early access and with
that set we're just going to start up I
will small intro and then sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we have a problem it is so good to
meet you there is something I want to
give you
it's already different enemies I'm spent
great so we're in character creation I
can select my background so these are
all the dungeon dragons backgrounds that
you know play dungeon dragons I could
slay change my body type
I can change my race so I can play as a
deep thing I can play as a drove it
plays a human there's a kit Yankee can
play as a dwarf there's an elf if
there's a half elf I can play as a half
throw there's a halfling and there's
more but we're only showing a few these
are the races that will be going into
early access and they're more will be
added afterwards and so depending on
which race I think I get different
features I can also select which class
I'm gonna play we have six classes that
wouldn't available on early access from
the get-go and then we'll just as before
we progress so I can place the wizard
cleric fighter Ranger ro and warlock and
then I can pick the abilities like
ability points that go with that and
select my skills and which I'm going to
be proficient today we're gonna play an
origin story so we have different origin
stories and there's gonna be five that
are gonna be an early access there will
be more often so this is my cell she's
the girl you saw in the intro so she is
a Yankee girl is a wizard he has a very
big problem and that's pretty much that
he's going to explode and shadowheart
she's a dark cleric as 40-story - well
as a monster hunter who made a pact with
the devil he regrets it
and today we're gonna play as a star in
who is a vampire spawn he's a noble so
vampire spawn is not really vampire he
has a vampire vampire to which he is a
slave he is a high elf which means that
we get to select a counter for him she's
gonna pick mage hand because we're gonna
do cool things with it
and all the rest is already preset for
him so we just have to click the venture
forth button and we can continue
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so we're gonna skip the tutorial because
it's not ready yet
and so I'll tell you what happens in
tutorial or at least in a nutshell we're
gonna capture that note annoyed we're
going to do that together with to get
young ki a warrior that you so captured
in the intro and we're gonna teleport it
to a place called faerûn more
specifically to the sword coast more
specifically two hundred miles to the
east of baldur's gate that was by the
way the city that you saw the sword is
no bulbs gate it was your car
how's this coming so what I forgot to
mention is that my vampires form and
normally come walk in the sunlight he
can't go over running water and he needs
an invitation if he wants to enter
somewhere but apparently he can walk in
the sunlight so that's kind of handy for
us so he's going to try to figure out
what's going on so I can't control the
camera and put it in third person so
then it's running behind me or I can
just go back top-down and then basically
play it in a traditional manner so I'm
going to like going like this and that's
fine
over there
[Music]
sunlight
so this is a river Volga try alternate
let love push my land it reaches all the
way to baldur's gate but we have no boat
so we're gonna have to go in a different
direction obviously no fun over here
sure under the law that there's none of
my business
sky always this blue it's magnificent
starting doesn't really care about the
fact that everybody's dead
she is banging at the door so listen to
ask and introduce ourselves
blast it doors I what huh it's you I saw
you on the ship you survived then
suddenly I saw what she saw felt what
she felt anger confusion results
you've got the same thing I do in your
head I felt it
okay so I have a whole bunch of dialogue
options so what just happened to us is
because of the tadpole I was already
introduced to that in tutorial we call
it mind-melding so we both have a
tadpole in our heads and we can
telepathically connect to each other but
I'm also very hungry so I'm playing this
from point of view of a star in vampire
spawn and so you will see that all of my
choices will be tailored to being a star
and essentially so I'm gonna stare at
her and realize that I'm very hungry
as that tadpole scrambled your brain
already so I can basically say okay well
I'll just feed or I can swallow my urge
and find ignorance which is what I'm
going to do because I needed a companion
the chase through hell
the creatures what they did to us the
tadpole that thing is going to consume
us from the inside and turn us into mind
flares you and I need a healer finding
one won't be easy in this wilderness
we'll need supplies I'm hoping something
of use might be behind these doors but I
barely made a dent in them so far okay
so I can offer to help her but I'm a
rogue also so I can tell her to save her
strength then that I will pick the lock
by all means I'm going to see what's at
the top of this cliff
hopefully there's no more of these
creatures along the way I will
well actually I suggest that we join
forces and say that gives us better also
survival just company for our final
moments but you're right whatever lies
ahead will be a little less daunting
with support you can call me shadowheart
I can tell her that I'm a star in a
reformed vampire spawn we can walk in
the sunlight or can choose not to tell
her which is a good idea and I can also
question her what she knows about the
things in each of our heads
very little supposedly those monsters
breed by planting their tadpoles in
people's heads over time the infected
victim turns into a mind flare I don't
remember how long it takes but we should
hurry so that's a problem
I didn't reduce myself Starion lead the
way sorry and I've made my first
companion that's right so walk make that
door but I don't have a little big
oops and I got myself into the door
alright
and see this fine gentleman has
something of use but you don't
[Music]
that's usually an introduction to combat
when you see something like that let's
try and see what it is
and so combat is turn-based it goes
tension and drags a turn-based system so
okay so stuff on that I need to be very
careful for these intellect of words
because if they get too close to me they
will be very painful this can actually
end up in the party wives without do my
very best to let them dry I'm gonna
stick the high ground and dungeon
dragons seeking advance which allows you
to roll twice which is a good idea
because a lot of dice rolling going on
behind the scenes as you'll soon see we
translate the dice rolls into
percentages so that you don't have to do
all the mathematics yourself so that
gives me a 90% chance to hit so that's a
pretty good one also
I'll manage don't worry about it that's
a 45 percent disagree but that's why I'm
calling second fire too puny to damage
so if you're curious to know how the
calculations are going happening they're
happening behind the scenes here you can
just hover over it and then you can
learn all of the math behind the numbers
that you see which is why Jessie said
lots of numbers we're gonna be very
brief and we're just gonna go up there
and then I'm gonna see how far I can get
this target because I don't want him to
die right away
alright shadowheart really me just my
recruiter the boom is action these are
my actions these are my bonis action so
you just see yeah it says ap it's a
little bit misleading yeah but it's
actually just the actions that you have
but sometimes you can have two of them
so I'm going to end my turn
I know it's the enemy's turn
unfortunately they can turn that's good
you can hit me that's actually not that
bad so what I'm gonna do with
shadowheart is I'm gonna try something
that's a little bit risky but sometimes
worse I'm going to use the shop and I'm
going to try to
so that guy's a little bit further for
me and then she can still hammer at that
guy really not hitting very well and
then I'm gonna shoot the deterrent at
that guy we're doing pretty good
actually
so common is fairly high stakes as you
can see so they have reactions that
basically means if she walks away from
here they're going to hit her which is
not good so what I'm gonna do and he and
he comes so I have a job I didn't want
to use it yet but first I'm going to
jump as a bonus action
that means that I can't use another film
is actually but it acts as a disengage
also and it's in the house why might
that fall that I have inside of me I do
have one action that I can still do so
I'm just gonna try it up this is my mage
hands my match hand is bad that's many
things but it's very good at throwing
stuff so I'm gonna
[Applause]
I wanted to show this to you today but
you have no idea how nervous I was about
doing it because I was going to get in
this situation so I obviously should
have approached them in completely
different manner we'll see the next
comeback how you can actually be much
more strategic
alright she is hurting so she's gonna
drink my first giving potion I don't
have a lot of them then she's just gonna
actually
all right all right here comes that's
good oh no no no getting back up very
high stakes he's fighting for the shots
that's interesting
okay um mage hands where are you do your
thing
to 80% so sorry yeah you can also throw
bodies that you find in the world but
it's not working so that's why I'm using
the shot actually yeah it's working but
it doesn't look as good
oh why did I go to sleep i misclicked
really did I put my hand in to sneak
that's really clever
so either the announcement was that it
was going to be life I think so alright
90% shot that should oh yeah actually I
have a pin down in back which is a
action that you get with your weapon so
each point that you get gives you an
extra type of action yes your I know
that you're sneaking you got this you
got this I have a plan
I got a boat a little bit grease so I'm
just gonna - can you stop hands alright
normally he's not supposed to be able to
hit like this actually can you can't you
do anything useful if they want to
attack you maybe
okay all right so either dip your hands
here hand is not supposed to die but
well swimmingly okay so I wanted to
throw so I have a true action I can
throw pretty much everything in a
presentation I did finish you have
through my boots so for comedic effect
I'll just throw my boots maybe I'll
actually just killing that's not
actually
so where is she does one of those
anymore
that's so she's down she's not dead yet
so that's the good news
so basically how this works is this is
def saving TRO so each turn there's
gonna be a role behind the scenes and if
it's a good role and then we're gonna
get a little blue spot like this and if
you have three of them she gets
stabilized which is cool and if we get
three red ones because it's a bad role
then she dies and there are going to
keep on hitting at her because if she
goes to the negative over maximum HP she
dies too so we're gonna try to avoid
that from happening but I'm really not I
shouldn't have thrown this by the way
that was really stupid move this looks
like a really good kid that's excellent
and we have one guy left thank you
why huh
okay well let's hope that this one's
gonna go right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay well I I did tell you that oh no
Stella hold on this is all right so so I
do have the same problem is real so it
is genuine so I need to restart so I'm
just going to do a quick restart I'll
just do it as fast and then we'll just
we'll do Q&A for five minutes
you got it out of the way early yeah
that's why they gave us a half hour
extra day absolutely you're fine
I'll just sneak past a fight and we'll
go to the next one
otherwise we might be in trouble luckily
for you they mattress image and venture
form go forward into the game and I will
recruit shadowheart again so I'll do
that in the shortest possible manner and
then I suggest we try to avoid the
intellect divorce take a different route
if we can and if we can't well we'll
have to fight them again before we
proceed with our adventure so yeah I've
done this like we've done press tour in
the last three weeks and I've done this
like 30 40 times I in general do not die
on it although it's
meanwhile we can also look at a few
others on the game
don't make him walk over there
starting to run run the story and run
run run run over here thank you
so meantime we can have a look at the
back side of the UI so this is where you
see all my equipment here you see all of
my abilities so when you click on the
sky your skills distances and this is my
spell book where the spells that I had
no blasted doors like what oh it's you I
saw you on the ship you survived then
suddenly I saw what she saw felt what
she felt anger confusion
you've got the same thing I do in your
head
I felt it okay so I'm just gonna be very
nice and the creatures what they did to
us the tadpole that thing is going to
consume us from the inside and turn us
into mind flares you and I need a healer
finding one won't be easy in this
wilderness we'll need supplies I'm
hoping something of use might be behind
these doors but I barely made a dent in
them so far I'm gonna help you my guest
but that doors too strong maybe there's
another way up the cliff
hopefully there's no more of these
things or just company for our final
moment but you're right whatever lies
ahead will be a little less daunting
with support you can call me shadowheart
yeah I'm a star lead the way started
do you want to take an audience vote on
if we do this fight again
okay so now I'm doing I'm gonna play it
like a pro do it really well and I'll
show a few other things first of all I'm
gonna dip my bow into the fire there we
go
then I'm gonna press this button which
allows me to enter turn-based mode
outside of combat and so in that way you
can sneak up on people and you can do
all kinds of things that they don't
expect you to do and then basically the
way that that works is that they have
six seconds oh yeah see these are the
enemy's turn
so they get to patrol for six seconds
they're not doing anything that's good
you see that over there that's explosive
so I'm gonna try to get there
96
[Applause]
cutter heart is still waiting for me
I'll make her join home that much better
I feel much more relaxed about this
fight
I'm gonna pin him down there you go this
is how it's supposed to be and then I
did actually have a very strong attack
but I never got to use it which is
guiding balls and put them gonna use it
now where's the other guy but put her in
front of it
- Thomas you
[Music]
you can't move anymore that's good the
other guy very enthusiastically coming
towards us she's going to use her
guiding voltage in generally to kill
them in one shot there you go you know
damage and then we're going to shoot
[Applause]
alright that was exciting
this guy he's got a silver locket and
dagger I don't need the Decker I got one
already but the rapier I might want to
use that one go and go for it and
explore a little bit more see the world
has to offer us
so like in all of our games you can move
to things in the environment but we've
got we've added a whole bunch of stuff
that you can do so we can print and make
a stair why would you make us there
it's fine you're doing great it's fine
well
I think ok so here's another example of
why you would want to do a turn-based
mode
say that you want to kill this war or
off to it or whatever you can now just
press the button and then you can just
plan your move goes to it and then it
has six seconds so I press my spacebar
now it will move for six seconds then
it's my turn
well it will use this to surprise people
and sneak up on them and hopefully do it
really well
just gonna try to jump over although I
think actually
that usually are stirring the dice this
is an example of a passive check so my
nature skill was used to discover
something
if it would have failed I would know
pounded of course I found the old cache
the cache belongs to the Harper's sir
gives me a little secret but it's
specially this thing that I need the
support of speech it will double my
Newton points and it's going to also
allow to get to actions which is really
good
we're gonna try it very complicated
stunts probably succeed or fail see what
I did there probably succeed or fail
this seems as good a place as any to
make camp and rest might as well adapt
the daywalkers ways so your camp is a
play that's going to expand over time
you will be able to get followers in
your camp your companions will obviously
be here also and so there's a lot of
relationship building happening in your
camp I'm not sure this is a good idea I
can tell her not to question me or but
I'm gonna try to befriend her some come
ask her what she needs there are lit
fuses in our heads sooner or later
they're going to blow each hour that
passes the thing inside is gross we need
to find a healer let's wake up at first
light okay I'm going to agree with her
and because finding help is indeed our
very first concern maybe we'll get lucky
we're overdue some good fortune rest
well will lead our strength
I've tried to rest but my mind wouldn't
settle just yesterday I had been
seducing a young man luring him to my
Master's lair since then I've been
kidnapped by mine flares chased through
Hell by dragons and fallen from the sky
and I felt the Sun on my skin I should
have burst into flames
so I can ask myself questions will be
the moment of introspection I can think
of my master it will be furious to be a
vampire spawn yeah actually it's a good
question can I have vampires form even
become a my player the worm in my head
might not even have an appetite for
undead meat until I knew more about the
tableau I wasn't sure how much danger I
was in I had to understand it master it
I needed to find someone who knew more
about this thing so I'm going to try to
get some sleep and I'm gonna imagine
dragging my old master into the sunlight
and that's the persuasion against myself
so I need to roll I need to do it in
thousands check basically so the way
that works is actually there's a
built-in Moni fires on it and that we
just show you the actual VC that comes
out at the end I drifted off with a
smile meditating on the flames that
engulfed his cruel face gonna be happy
morning okay
so all of the dialogues in the game like
literally all of them have been
performance captured for sale recorded
given cinematic treatment and there
hasn't been any compromise because of
old cinematic that we're doing in there
so there's plenty of permutations and
you need to realize that I'm now playing
with a star in so it wouldn't be playing
with a star and we would have different
things happening to us and you'll see
that we've gone very far in this dead
Copeland's over there worth checking for
supplies maybe this here
[Music]
that's unexpected last I saw you you
were lying in a crucibles worth of blood
an intellect devour and nibbling in your
air glad to see my eyes deceive me I'm
Gail well met
so my vampire option is that I send
something off I was certainly good
tastes like bile I can obviously draw my
weapon cuz I don't trust a guy
speechless might be the shock we went
through a traumatizing experience if I'd
instructive one asked if I throw my hit
her to the thing they put in my eye yes
the ocular penetration by on a lifted
tadpole which will end with our souls
being snuffed like strands of we've
caught in dead magic not to mention
you're staring at me like a Roisin me on
a blackboard
no no wizard are you I can obviously
just decide two feet but I will tell him
that I don't take kindly to insults
thin-skinned and a daughter of questions
usually means the answer's no guess
that'll have to wait
primary need now is a healer I take it
you recall the insertion of the parasite
not only do they recall it I said I was
already enjoying its effects referring
to the fact that I can walk in the Sun
interesting are you aware that after a
period of excruciating gestation it'll
turn us into mind flayers process known
as Sarah morphosis it is to be avoided I
assume your no accomplished healer
either powerful cleric maybe okay what's
this a conversation or an interrogation
just trying to figure out where we stand
conclusion nowhere you and I are in a
whole lot of trouble
we need help I'm not sure where we'll
find it in this wilderness how about we
embark on the quest for a healer
together yes excellent then without
further ado let's be off besides looks
like you keep some interesting company a
woman with shadows for eyes deep as the
dark lake pleasure madam is it indeed
we'll see
there
she's gonna do a few things for I
actually had to kill them so I'm gonna
separate him from my party because I
know what's coming so I want to show you
something
and I'm gonna go with them well actually
I'm first gonna position him because
these guys this can turn out that the
other combat so
and so the way sneaking works and the
ball circuitry is that if you see a
shadow it's gonna lightly obscure you
all right if you walk into the sunlight
you are going to be in the clear area so
when you're in a clear area and you get
seen you are caught on sight if you go
into a obscured area then you have to
roll stealth 20 and if you get caught
you get caught which might actually
succeed if you are heavily obscured as
you will soon see you can actually just
it's kind of cool because every single
shadow suddenly has use but there's also
music amela played shadows you can light
or move light and is here standing on
this creative process he does I'm just
gonna leave him here
and then I'll go over here and
demonstrates smoking that I just
discovered this morning because so
normally what I do here go first of all
I show that you still have all kinds of
environmental interactions that you can
use everything that makes sense within
the world of dragon you can paper ice
water which fire but there's also other
good things that you so normally I just
show this and I say okay well this is
where we are we start from here
basically I do it to show that you can
navigate over very high in vertical
world but I figured that if I cast
feather fall then I make it
so she's a nice fellow item if she would
have jumped without feather for maybe we
can do that too
you'll die anyway no he has to walk back
[Music]
feather falls are very useful spell the
game has an enormous amount of
verticality will never get the places
where the verticality is implying today
because we don't have enough time and we
introduced it to gradually two players
but you will be surprised by how much
stuff you can do we can walk on roofs
you can jump all the way down into very
very very deep holes just going to get
the feather pole wrong with feather
falls it takes up a sir if you if you
use it all right that's good thing I was
supposed to do so let's regroup them
there's a small problem with the
interface here so you know though we see
their group but they should be good
hopefully
so let's go meet these fine gentlemen
and say hello to them you pal twice as
tall as me but I'm off that bloody
backbone but we don't know what that
thing even is and what about the Crypt
I'm telling you it's a ship and the
Crypt come wait Mari and Barton have
been trying to break in for days now we
stop got ourselves competition already
that's our ship okay so we have a bunch
of persuasion options I can tell them
that I was just looking around tell them
that the ship was full of monsters my
many comrades were coming so I can try
to intimidate them you're gonna tell
them but there's plenty of monsters and
then which is fine I mean you're old hot
ya think you can get us to leave that
bounty to you not a chance
what are you not waiting for dinner
[Music]
luckily for me I planned for this and so
if you do a shot out of a sleep position
that is a whole new set chance
[Music]
okay so that was my action for this one
it's trying to do this really well I'm
going to use Greece Greece is going to
trade difficult strange and difficult
terrain is basically going to half their
movements people as they're trying to go
over it so that's good also we made
Greece flammable so if I can Maya
put fire on it it's going to hurt them
double and of course they have no source
of fire anymore because I used up my
fire
so let's see
somebody's gonna have to stand there
that's a witch bowl so she can every
turn as long as is concentrated this is
gonna be able to hurt me
I need to do something about that this
guy's trying to go up to get to this
office back
I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to use
the cheat here no oh okay yeah no I just
worked I actually destroyed his father
since secretly with a secret secret but
she'll remain secret well Mitch over at
his office first okay well let's just do
it this eat what did he get
not that you can actually jump on them
also and that person do so with a
warrior with feather poll before it's
combined up and then jump on somebody
that converge however this was actually
really everybody it was just a throw I
can still shoot I need to make this hits
because otherwise shadow art is gonna be
in trouble
that will be a pin down 75%
so that means that she is now
I'm sorry their skills it's like I was a
little bit too in suggesting something
it went away
[Music]
don't forget
all right so our bar are you
I'm hitting it
so far from us they don't have any
quietly
she can - make her -
you'll get very far but getting a bit
farther that cancels the entire effect
then maybe I yell at them I don't yell I
don't have a yell yet we will have that
big time
need to make this here
I got a thing you know one three start
again
late again yes thank you
that's why you guys are here we have
magic pockets we have magic pockets
you're basically telling me to run away
right
oh well having a having an excellent
idea this is going to work really well
so let me well let me first write did
that throw something already over
against Oldham I can't remember
good work
new partes well as for see which
direction they're gonna go actually
because I can go back I can get most of
our giver helping hands
again
all right we're gonna make
Marshtomp encephalitis that sounds
do it again
I'm throw Decker makes a bit more sense
yeah before I mean actually those Peaks
[Music]
we'll get there it might be hard to work
though Oh actually but what I can still
do no I got the spoon again that's right
all right
it happens that you miss a lot anyway
today I think's looks at everything that
is not alright so out of combat there
deaf stepping through oh she's really
dead she's dead there yeah
we'll worry about her later to relieve
her there
she deserves it well let's first see
what they had
don't reach standing next to her sex
date let's give this to you
fancy stuff make them look more like a
real wizards
he's a rope a beard now
worth mentioning afford that BK you can
play the game him of the barrel sir
there you can equal origin stories I
have to mention it you can play as
everybody is a hero
so much of a personality they
multiplayer like meant with being able
to participate in each other stars in
what year other options another person
is considering something that can quite
intense as you'll see soon
okay so we're gonna go inside here like
you keep a book everything all right out
there I'm gonna claim to be gibble book
and ask him to let me you don't worry
we're safe if it fails broken do you
sound the be shaken boss hang on while I
find the key
[Music]
you're dead nope you're just and please
why is because I demand when you
surprise somebody you get a mission
so this guy has absolutely no chumps the
first thing I'm gonna do is I'm going to
go over here I'm going to shoot there
you go and then I'm gonna shoot him
again then I know he's gonna try to run
away horse his buddy's just fine shoot
him again
and that's how easy it can be
alright let's see where we end up
I star in the great tomb raider he's
gonna do all this on his own just as a
demonstration of how systemic use of all
systems can be great for this place
again just
okay so I'm gonna switch the lights off
I'm gonna go sneak out and I'm going to
put myself into four stern basements and
I'm gonna try to sneak up behind this
one so I can she's probably gonna start
turning back so I'm gonna go and stand
the corner here I'm heavily obscured I
don't come too close they are not gonna
detect me all right I just gonna stand
there now there she is this is a reason
why so you have a little hole here why
because this slides is creating assuming
that she can see in and then zoom just
in front of her birth here that we're
standing here I would have been actually
okay
[Music]
hello this is my sneak attack so if I do
it formally I get 1d6 extra damage was
[Music]
I'm gonna bite through yes I'm gonna
keep my bite for later
okay so I'm gonna go over here this is
safe
to take my dipping action didn't torch
my sword my boat my arrows actually so
what suggested and somebody put a [ __ ]
battle here for me this is cool sticking
out over this crates darkness
let's try to do that again so the trick
here is that I'm gonna try to get into
this place
[Music]
so we're gonna create a zone of darkness
so the zone of darkness is basically
going to cover me so that he can't see
me while I'm in there
wait
so the artist
I was actually quite
[Music]
[Music]
of course we're still working on better
visualization of this but starting the
great doom greater has managed to do
something because being detected all
right let's continue
so our doors open
[Applause]
I like it
also notice how the music changes when
you start music system is super adaptive
all right this has a tendency of going
wrong I'll do my outro best this is a
thank you a dangerous mix here skeletons
lying on the floor and there's things
that are popping up and I have
perception checks that are succeeding
that are failing so you know that
something's gonna happen and then
there's this big thing in the middle
inside they have grease appearing
everywhere fire appearing so but I knew
exactly where to stand and I'm gonna
interface because turn-based move is
also something that you can use to
navigate traps you got six seconds to
think and then the traps are get their
turn and you get your turn so you get
the gist so the way that I figured out
is getting out of here it's a chance can
throw stuff and so what I can do so that
I can make my own stairs so I can make a
stair out of here
and then back to mage hands
I got a do it the way that the way that
I'm doing it because I practiced this
when I its wrongly I drew it too far the
creative damage and then I jumped on top
of it and then the credit destroy it and
then I died anyway so
so having turn-based mode allows us to
do much cooler traps and not having you
to require to have lightning-fast
reflexes in order the game which has
many many spells many many actions that
you can do so it's kind of
okay gonna do my little jump now
there's no space there is enough space
man why do you have to follow me chance
[Music]
all right well that's that's handy hm
receptions like we're successful because
I'm supposed to have a perception check
but you have to do it but that's cool
because then I can actually throw this
thing on that that way there's no more
grease coming out of it you think I can
make it
you have to stop
all right this is a bit harder than I
expected it to be
that's gonna take that grease away and
that's just see what I'm gonna get out
of it
my greatest broken
man well I'll bet I made the quarters
over here that's good
so so now we know that don't just have
my - get out of here eventually for a
second
you over there
yep
I'm not jinx it
again fall don't fall ok we made it
outside of the very evil trap
[Music]
so we're gonna get to the final room of
this mini dungeon so this is kind of
situation you'll find yourself in if
you're in multiplayer and you're just
dashing off and leaving your party
behind you can always manage it's just
sometimes a little bit so many no signs
so we're entering a big room and so the
you see a bunch of skeletons on the
floor so you are all gamers you know
what's gonna happen these guys are gonna
race so here's a little trick I figured
out yes I can take their weapons away
unfortunately because disarming somebody
is actually in valid action the AI
developers are making it so that they
will pick up the weapons that they if
they see something on the floor and
they're unarmed yeah I will actually
come to the same part the conclusion on
its own but luckily it's not implemented
yet we can take advantage of this today
I'm gonna give this guy's sort just so
that we can see the difference between
the guys have all of them I just want to
make sure that the guys with the bow
don't have
you have a book now there's not a
marksman over there yet I'm gonna try
the final heist this little tomb raiding
adventure and if I fail they'll be me
I'll then consider whether or not I'm
gonna resurrect them failed any Gale so
but Yale has a shortcut there was
actually a I can also bring a star into
expect so there's an actual shortcut but
I didn't want to do it because when you
do it it alerts the guards on the inside
and they all gang up and then I can't do
a starring on his own
if you shoot this thing and somebody
standing under it he'll die but it also
creates a whole
and then we find ourselves into this
room here and then like this I can open
this room that was a shortcut but then
they basically all the banners that are
in this dungeon then stand outside of
this door and they're ready to kill you
where is it
so here would have a better chance of
doing a succeeding in a history check
which I think I know it's a perception
actually let's just try it up maybe
we'll we won't open it today
it's another secret the game is full of
secrets exploration is heavily rewarded
you will never see all the secrets in
one go it's impossible over here this is
the exit so this is where in a second
the start and we'll have to manage
okay so the reason why we came here is
because we want it we have poisons
that's fine because we can throw poison
people with all that skeletons of course
but this amount of joy and sorrow which
gives me to speak with that spell
so speaking with that is something that
you can do
ready to have a model
something just won't come unfortunately
I don't have myself I just realized that
this is the reason I keep my speed
potion in general
see
why are you standing here anyway let's
just hug the wall
wait for him to move
okay this should be easy at this point
[Music]
this is also why we need some better
indications so that we're working on
because this looks bright because the
artistic with the light here but for the
game it's actually it's a heavily
obscured soon things that were still
need to fix
alright I'll be good I think with the
potion of speed that was already out of
here somebody made me drink it
while I'm heavily obscured they actually
have dark vision so they actually it
should have been a check so I think that
they the dark vision does work but it's
fine it's good I mean like look we're
almost at the exit and they have no
arrows to have no bows they have no
weapons okay they all have their hands
like exactly how it should be the AI is
trying to figure out what the hell am I
gonna do right I'm gonna - okay
don't do anything
all right and then that's my movement
bar by the way moving that half Gayle
joins the thing the action oh I only
have five minutes left
oh oh yeah I was my phone is charging I
forgot my timer so alright I I wanted to
show you one last thing
he gave up the keep is like I'm done
[Laughter]
I'm thinking that if I manage to click
it in here oh let me to let me do this
oh it's the hands
Oh
no-no-no
well okay well since I only have five
minutes
will be the end of my presentation
[Applause]
we have time for a few questions Jessie
do we yeah I mean there's already a guy
lining up go for it yeah all right I've
never played baldur's gate before and
based on what I've seen so far I really
really really want to now however my
luck is abysmal what advice do you have
for for someone with awful luck other
than you were asking him other than
playing on easy yeah so there's ways
that you can modify your dice you seek
out advantage which allows you to roll
twice so that's something that's
important we will have an easier mode we
still have to balance stuff also so the
values that you're seeing right now
we're pretty much straight out of the
book
so sometimes it's fairly harsh but we'll
make sure that when it gets to you this
is one of the reasons we're going to
early access it will be manageable
because as you can see it's very brutal
sometimes thank you can't wait to play
in it thank you
hi so quick question is it possible to
restock your companions
can you restart your companions so yes
you will be able to modify your
companions ability points and their
class
[Music]
yeah I called answer that question yet
okay thank you so the reason why I
couldn't answer your questions because
it's a point of discussion right now for
spell slots do they recharge after a
long rest or after long rest long rest
so you need to go back to camp actually
the next thing to we're gonna do was
resurrect them and go to camp and have a
camp moment so that we would respect and
then we actually had like a big finale
but we never go there sorry about making
you use that potion I know you said this
is early access and everything but
there's one interaction that happened
that I have to ask about you didn't just
tell anyone you were a vampire and you
walk up in a camp oh I'm gonna do like
the daywalkers do look at their
companion I didn't mean that
was that a a bug in the system where
she's supposed to react or yeah yeah
there was there was a small moment of a
note that it froze there didn't get
anything thank you
hi I wanted to ask what consoles is this
game me to be coming on I know it's
coming out on like stadia I think PC and
so understanding that this game is a
pretty much removed from the previous
two baldur's gate games is there a
chance that we might see characters from
our previous adventures such as a
particular Ranger with a hamster
companion today so that question just
curious the part where you attacked the
ear companion I noticed that was sort of
a real-time combat are we going is it
going to be strictly turn-based like we
saw or everything is happening in
turn-based so that was actually she
didn't react to it she should have
reacted but her reaction system isn't
ready yet so she should have reacted to
the fact that I stabbed her so but no
combat is turn-based dungeon dragons
turn-based and we wanted to do a port
that was as faithful as we could but
still makes for a good video game and by
doing it this way we can actually pretty
much do one-on-one mapping of a lot of
of systems and that works quite well
some big fan of Boas gate I had a
question is there gonna be like an
alignment system is it gonna impact with
kind of how the storyline plays so less
pronounced and it used to be so and when
we started out working on it we actually
also had in our heads we're gonna make
alignment a really big thing but then
wizards actually asked us a little bit
to tone it down because they didn't want
it to make it that that black and white
anymore however you are going to
depending on your action so you have
good character scale is a good character
for instance he's not going to stay very
long with you if you're going to keep on
doing very very very crazy evil things
and it's a real pity that we didn't get
to the end of my presentation because I
was going to do the ultimate evil thing
I was gonna bite one of my companions at
night
but it failed but there will be a lot of
press up and you will be able to see it
in the stuff that they have had to talk
about and I was going to let you decide
whether or not we're going to do the
bite and then whether or not we're going
to completely drain my companion or
leave a little bit of blood and all that
and kind of yes of course I mean but you
it's your choice right you roll with
your choices and then then there's a d20
that you have to roll to makes it to do
to see if she actually detects it or not
I wish to kind of cool what kind of
follow-up to that will your actions
affect your alignment like if you start
off good and make a bunch of evil
choices so whether your alignment is
going to change so we actually don't
show alignments right now in the game so
there is no modification of alignment
for the moment - Manchester knighted
three Club Brugge nil Adam Smith he's
one of the senior writers on ballers
Gate three he's a Manchester United fan
I'm from Bruges is in Belgium and our
teams were playing now as the
presentation started and so he just felt
this was necessary hey they're huge fan
you guys had a quick question regarding
early access could you talk a little bit
more about that like rough estimate for
a release date how much of the campaign
is gonna be ready anything like that
wait there's somebody waving with the
time does that mean I have to shut up so
to answer your question so we're gonna
roll it into early access when bugs like
what you saw are all gone we're very
curious to get the community feedback so
that's the thing that's very important
for us I will make sure there's enough
content in there to keep you busy we'll
make sure that you don't have all the
content so that when release comes
you'll get plenty of content to play
through pretty much like we did with our
previous games but I can't give you the
exact figures on that
last question in a world of legendary
heroes one man will rise
to take all
of the credit this game has something
that no one else will this is where the
magic hey can I get a copy everybody has
that game that they fell in love with
because they make an impact those games
were somebody's legacy well this is my
legacy a legacy I don't like to see
whatever it's not my legacy
I have a BA in women's studies what
exactly is women's studies all the
experiences of women and the
contributions they've made some inquiry
withdrawn good thing I'm worried about
the time
yeah David I'll move it as fast as I can
it's not my fault that these watermelons
don't explode like real heads I can get
you real heads not human that's
commitment I built your vision it's like
you're this brilliant painter and I'm
your favorite brush I'm just some tool
to create your masterpiece
I like that metaphor but it's not quite
right is it seriously about to noodle on
my metaphor right now
I know that I can be difficult you can't
give up like the Beatles
together we make masterpieces I could
write the lyrics and the music and
everything but it would sound completely
different without the drums
wait I'm Ringo oh yeah of course your
brain you look somebody's got to keep
the beat oh my god at least you've
brought me breakfast oh this is mine
it's prescription a prescription bagel
legally you're actually not allowed to
ask me about
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]